hello
to all voters out there whether you are
republican
or democrat red or blue
dead or alive whether you voted once
or five times whether you mailed it in
or
showed up at the polls this is the
reuben report direct message for
november
5th 2020. i'm dave rubin
and we are about uh a day and a half out
of the election
and nobody knows what the high hell's
going on
i mean good god lord help us
uh we got a lot to talk about i'm gonna
try not to get you guys
all caught in the every little moment
someone at a pole
looked at somebody this way and this guy
touched that thing and all of that
there's all kinds of wacky stuff
happening right now
uh of course we're gonna have to talk
about this within the context
of big tech censorship which is the
first story that i'm gonna cover because
uh i don't know if you know about this
but these big tech companies
they may not be looking out for us
people they may
just be there to promote a narrative i'm
starting to think so i haven't
fully formulated this theory yet but i'm
i'm starting to think so
so we're going to talk a little bit
about big tech and censorship and what's
going on with trump's tweets because
they keep censoring his tweets but not
not biden's tweets overall we'll talk
about how
it was pretty much a decent election
down ticket for republicans uh here's a
stat by the way you're not going to hear
on mainstream news really uh 35
of muslims voted for president trump the
most
anti-muslim president and anthony this
president anthony that president and
everything
uh he also got the highest as i talked
about yesterday the highest
non-white vote by a republican since
1960 the highest percentage something
like 26 percent
which obviously that could change a
little bit on the margins
uh we'll talk about what's going on a
little bit with these states because
everything's kind of upside down
and depending on who you're listening to
it sounds like it's in the bag for biden
or it sounds like it's in the bag for
trump or it sounds like
it's in the bag to never end so we'll
talk a little bit about that we'll also
talk
about some some voter fraud stuff
that that seems pretty crazy out of
arizona and will actually show video
and then you can decide and then
actually spectacular
news you guys know i was going crazy
about this prop 16
thing here in california where we were
literally
putting discrimination back into the
system
we were going to say that yes the
government should
hire based on race and gender and skin
color and all of those things
and it actually got rejected i am
shocked
something sane happened here in
california
i can't believe it i don't know how it
happened but something saying actually
happened here in california michael
let's talk about ancestry before we get
to anything else
guys this holiday season will
undoubtedly be like no other families
may not have the opportunity to be
physically together due to covet 19
social distancing and financial
restraints
all sorts of travel stuff i told you
guys you know i host thanksgiving at my
house usually but it doesn't look like
we're gonna be able to do it this year
unfortunately
uh despite the events that may keep us
apart physically ancestry brings you
closer to family past and present
through your shared history
ancestry is the family activity and
gifting solution for the highly unusual
2020 holiday season actually my my
grandma's
cousin who lives here in los angeles who
i connected with the last couple years
she's 94 years old she's our family
genealogist and she's used ancestry
to help track my family back over 250
years
actually into europe pretty pretty
amazing the holiday salad ancestry is
the perfect time to treat someone you
love with a gift that connects them to
family in new meaningful ways
find amazing prices on gifts that will
let your family explore their past
share fascinating stories and discover
the places around the world
their ancestors called home an ancestry
dna test can tell you where your
ancestors are from and ancestry's
billions of records and millions of
family trees let you discover their
unique stories
don't miss special holiday pricing on
truly meaningful gifts during
the holiday sale at ancestry head to my
url at ancestry.com to get your ancestry
gift
today that's ancestry.com reuben and now
back to me
all right so let's let's start by
talking about
the messaging part of what's happening
right now because
you guys all know this there's a lot of
stuff happening on the ground right
there's
there's recounts and they're trying to
figure out what
postmarked date things can happen in
pennsylvania specifically in philly
now it seems like arizona may be turning
back towards trump there's a lot of like
stuff happening on the ground and i'll
get you a quarter sort of up to speed on
the numbers
but at some level i think that actually
is starting to become
secondary to our ability to actually get
the information again this is the
reality war that i keep telling you guys
about
it's like if we don't have a mainstream
media layer
and then a big tech layer to get us the
information so if you think about it
this way it's like stuff's happening on
the ground right
so there's a reality happening on the
ground that that may be legit
that may be fraudulent some in some
places it might be legit some places it
might be frozen like there's all those
different combinations of different
things that are happening in different
states
with different governors and with
different uh
with different attorney generals etc etc
and by the way the attorney general
of philadelphia and some of the election
officials there they're outward biden
supporters that does seem a little
problematic as the kids say
um so there's that layer and then you
have okay whatever happens the reality
of what happens whether it's
true or not in terms of the numbers but
you have that
then above that you have the mainstream
media is going to report on it in a
certain way and then above that you have
big tech
which allows us to see what mainstream
is talking about or what the online
people are talking about and then they
censor stuff or don't censor stuff in
the rest of it
this all leads us to the reality war and
i think you probably remember
about two weeks ago it was it was
literally i think about
i don't know seven eight days before the
election when uh
congress the senate specifically hauled
in the big tech guys again right they
had jack dorsey from twitter and
zuckerberg from facebook
and there were some nice moments you
know ted cruz going off on
uh on jack from twitter and all of that
but as i
said then and i think i've turned out to
be correct it's like guys
the ship has left yeah
like what what did you think you were
gonna do by scolding them a few days
before the election now
you all know my feelings on on
regulation i don't love regulation maybe
the companies should have been
broken up maybe they should have scaled
back more legal protections all of those
things and that that's a great debate to
have and i'll continue to have that
debate by the way
um but the idea that we just did this a
few days before the election as if
anything could be done for this election
and now we're seeing it in real time
we're seeing them censor tweets
and it seems like they only censor
tweets from people on the right most
notably they're
they're censoring a lot of trump's
tweets and i want to get to some of them
so
let's throw up some of these trump
tweets it doesn't even matter
specifically what trump is saying
in these tweets it really doesn't as to
whether it's 100 true or 100
false or whether he's being sarcastic or
over the top or any of that
the point is that this is why
the free speech debate in america
was so connected to the big tech debate
because
right now i want you to think about it
is the government coming for your free
speech in any way
right this moment not really
not really that isn't to say it can't
happen of course it can happen and we
have to watch out for that that's the
beauty of the first amendment which i
have no doubt the progressives will
will come for soon enough um but
that's not the issue meaning the
government coming for your free speech
is not the issue
suddenly right after an election
twitter is censoring one of the
candidates tweets now
this is a problem this is a problem
they're also canceling a couple accounts
there was this count
account that was doing a really nice
tracking of what was happening
at all these polling stations then a lot
of people were retweeting it suddenly
that disappeared
some of my tweets there was a tweet by
uh
538 that's nate silver's polling thing
that gets everything wrong and yet
everyone thinks this guy's a genius
um and they tweeted that in one of the
states something they found suddenly out
of nowhere something like 24
uh was 2400 votes 2400 votes
and all of them in their own tweet it
said all of them went to bite and that's
basically
mathematically impossible so i i
retweeted it and i said well shouldn't
they lie within the margin of error so i
was making a little joke but
in essence i was just saying it's
obviously a lie and it's like
my tweet actually got censored by
twitter people couldn't retweet it they
couldn't share
it they couldn't like it and everything
else a ton of people sent me that they
sent me videos of trying to do it
but they didn't stop the 538 one
from going out there so it's like anyway
i know this is a little minutia stuff
at some level but the point is the
reality war is here and your ability to
figure out and find and
and pilfer out of the nonsense what is
true is a big problem
and and again it's only going one way
you know biden yesterday tweeted
something about in 71 days or something
when i'm president
you know this or that will happen and
it's like well isn't that
misinformation because you're basically
saying that you won the election
now we know if trump did that there
would have been a warning but when biden
does it
there is no warning so so this is all
this is all mess it's a mess people um
but actually i want to i want to step
back before i jump to the other story
and say something else that
i mentioned on the show yesterday that
i'm i'm feeling pretty good about things
in a certain way
and that like i'm not feeling crazed
about life at the moment i think there
are some crazy
things out there but as i said i don't
view my whole life just through the
political ends and i hope that you guys
don't either i hope
that you have a philosophical lens and i
hope you have family and friends that
you care of and
care about and love and i hope you eat
some decent food and get to do some
things that you like to do and all of
those things
so i do have those things i've worked
hard to have those things and and
so that's why i'm not feeling crazy but
i realized last night
um i was just it was like nine or ten
o'clock and i was just laying there
and i'm like flipping through hulu and i
can't really find anything and
and i find that's usually where like the
more interesting
um introspective thoughts come from
is you know where you're just like doing
nothing and then suddenly your mind is
just like oh remember this and what i
what i thought was
the reason that i'm feeling pretty good
about things is that no matter what
happens right now
i know that i did what i thought was
right like i really did i did what i
thought was right as i said
yesterday it's come at a cost personally
through friends and family and a whole
bunch of other stuff
i have no doubt that if trump loses like
there's going to be all sorts of people
that will try to destroy all of the
people that had anything to do
with trump or anything like that um but
i'm i'm really proud that
i stood up and said what i believe in
and you know when i glance through the
comment section here i i know that you
guys
in in some cases like i'm a proxy for
you because
it's a little harder for you to do it in
whatever your life circumstances are and
i totally sympathize with that and i
i wish there were there were some good
answers for it unfortunately the only
good answer
is that you got to step up too because
the more of us that do it it creates
that ripple effect but i know at the
individual level it can feel very scary
um and i i don't judge anyone for not
doing it i truly don't
i judge the public people who say one
thing publicly and
and say something else privately but but
for the average person just trying to
get by in the day i get it
but but anyway i mention all of that
because
because i think a lot of people feel
hysterical right now
because maybe they didn't do what they
should have done they didn't say what
they should have said
and then and then something happens and
you feel sort of out of control and it's
like i know i've done everything that
i can do here and i'm continuing to do
that so that's why i feel
kind of good and i just thought giving a
little of the personal side of that
would be good
um i want to throw quick to uh well i'm
not going to throw to it i'm just going
to
mention that um this guy
where's my paper here here it is i've
got a lot of papers here you know papers
if you have a lot of papers
that means you know what you're doing so
you can see i have a lot of papers here
uh joe koncha who's uh who's
a guy that actually strikes me as a as a
decent journalist believe it or not he's
an actual journalist radio host i've
done a show a couple of times
uh he tweeted out something interesting
i just saw it so we don't have the image
for it because i just saw it right
before we started like a minute before
but he mentioned and now work with me
here you may need a pen and paper for
yourself
if biden wins georgia if trump wins
north carolina
if trump wins pennsylvania and trump
wins nevada
and then trump flips arizona which is
very up in the air right now the trump
people say they're going to get it and
then trump wins
uh alaska which is likely so let's just
do that one more time
biden wins georgia trump north carolina
pennsylvania nevada arizona
and alaska you're not going to believe
this people
269 to 269
that's where we would be that's where we
would be so it is possible like
the thing is anything is possible at the
moment the whole system is flocked
in flux we have almost nobody in charge
you know i was thinking about this
who do you trust right now like i'm
gonna guess if some of you trust me and
that's great and i promise you that i'm
doing the best
i can i really i really really am
you know i as i say all the time i think
you know where my biases are
and i'm trying and if it turns out that
it's all legit
and biden wins then then so be it and
i'll and i'll move underground that
that's okay
um but i was thinking i don't have a lot
of people that i trust right now which
is making this increasingly harder and
harder like what institutions
would you say you trust like if this was
10 years ago i might have said that i
trust i
generally speaking i trust the new york
times well i don't trust the new york
times now obviously
what what academic institutions where we
could turn
to some scholars and say okay
you're non-partisan you're giving us an
honest
take on this where where is the class
of people that are supposed to be
sort of separate from like the political
craziness of the day
there's there's very very few of them
like thomas soul i trust thomas
also 91 and and not doing as much as he
used to
um you know like where are those people
um i think in in some cases this is
partly a failure
of the idw to to become something in the
long term it became something that was
important for about two years and then
as i've talked about for several reasons
i think it didn't
it didn't quite work and that's okay um
but like what was making the whole
intellectual dark web thing work when we
we were having those conversations with
a diverse group of people
is that we were really trying to fight
through the muck and like
come to some not necessarily agreement
but come to to some principles that we
could all live by
something like that and in effect uh
it's gone so i would love to know if you
know some institutions
some journalistic institutions you know
whatever it might be
that you trust some people out there
that are really making sense to you that
you want me to have on the show i would
love to have them on the show
because uh we need those people
we need those people and i assure you i
should not be at the top of the list
you know what i mean i'm just one guy
i'm doing what i can but like there
should be
there should be a lot of people doing it
and and yes of course there are some
other people
in this space that i think are basically
doing good work i think glenn beck is
basically doing good work i think ben
shapiro
is basically doing good work but again
these guys happen to align a little bit
more
with me ideologically so i would love to
see sort of a wide swath of people like
that
all right let's jump over to uh to some
of the voter fraud issues because this
is going to be one of the things
that when i talk about the reality war
it's the type of thing that you're going
to see online for now
until they start censoring it that
you're not going to see on cnn so
i would bet i'll bet you one american
dollar
that you're not going to see this image
that i'm about to show you these images
that i'm about to show you
on cnn but these seem pretty legit and i
actually saw the video in a follow-up
tweet we're going to show you some
images here
but i saw the video in the follow-up
tweet and there's many examples of this
and i recommend
don't take my word for it we're gonna
pull the images up right now so this is
at flekas on twitter and he's a he's an
independent journalist i've met him once
or twice interesting guy
[Music]
he took he went to the
michigan website and he started doing
some michigan voter information
searches and he was able to put in names
of people that are long since
dead long since dead like william
bradley
you know what year william bradley was
born in and you can see it here he put
all the information in
william bradley was born in 1902
that would make him 118 put in a zip
code the whole thing
and uh you're not going to believe this
william bradley 118 year old william
bradley who's dead he died in 1984 by
the way
yeah he was registered in uh wayne
county
in detroit and you're not going to
believe this guys it's even crazier and
you can see all the images here but
again go to fleca's account watch the
videos
see if you think this is something go do
it yourself he puts the link in there
go do it yourself find old dead people
and see if they voted
good god what is happening uh and yes
this guy voted his application was
received
on september 11 2020 and uh
the ballot was sent on 9 19 2020
and it was received about 12 days later
on 10
to 20 20. so congratulations
to 118 year old dead william bradley
from wayne county detroit you voted
your family must be very proud you see
why this is a problem guys like i i
don't mean to be silly about this stuff
but this is either something or it is
not and if you see these things online
and then the mainstream media just
ignores them
well then they're basically telling you
oh it is real but it doesn't fit our
narrative
so we can't show it to you or they're
saying we're just not in the business of
doing news now
i think it's some combination of both of
those things but again
don't take my word for it click the link
yourself
find some dead people see if they voted
that's a problem this man from
night born in 1902 did not
die dude did not die he's dead he's dead
he definitely died
he did not vote i'm pretty sure he did
not vote so
and you know what if you can prove that
this is fraudulent
go ahead and do that like like cnn a lot
of people are believing this right now
right like a lot of people are seeing
this in the twitter sphere
so if this is fraudulent if this is
nonsense
well how about you do a story and prove
it instead of just calling everybody
racist bigots and
and the rest of it how about how about
you do that um
okay i want to do one more story for
today as i said i don't want to bludgeon
you with every little oh my god that
this man
in philadelphia ate a cheese steak while
he was voting
we'll get through all of that but by the
way i will say this
it seems to me that this this has to end
up going much further to the courts like
i think the one thing that the system
did not account for
is that a trump is not a normal
republican who would just lay over and
die
he's going to fight this he's going to
fight this and again
i'm not telling you that everything
trump says even in those tweets that i
showed you is
true of course not you know what i mean
like trump is fighting
biden is fighting the media is fighting
everything else but now we've left it up
to our big tech overlords to discern
what is truthful
this is a major problem uh but let's end
on a little bit of good note here
uh prop 16 which i have been talking
about for a couple weeks in california
which was going to be a reversal of the
civil rights act now
civil rights we're all for civil rights
right i thought we were all for civil
rights it's one of those things it's
like
the middle east peace thing we were all
for it and now suddenly we're not so for
it because
i guess it has something to do with
orange man but
prop 16 in california was put on the
ballot and what they were going to try
to do was
reverse the civil rights act meaning
that the civil rights act of 1964
said in effect that you cannot the
government cannot discriminate when
hiring based on
skin color and sex et cetera et cetera
et cetera
i'll actually read you exactly what it
was it was california proposition 16 we
could put the image up there
it was to end the diversity ban so the
so everything about this was confusing
okay so
it repeals a constitutional provision
that made it
unlawful for california's state and
local governments to discriminate
against or grant preferential treatment
to people based on race ethnicity
national origin or sex so to
not discriminate based on those things
is good
and that's what we've had that you can't
discriminate on that this was put on the
ballot by the lefties by the bananas
progressives to reverse it because they
want
racism injected into the system in the
name of course
of anti-racism uh but what what really
concerned me about this although let me
just get you the numbers throw the image
up there for just a sec again
uh 56 so over 6.5 million people we got
a lot of people here in california
56 percent of people said no we don't
want
to inject systemic racism into our
government which is exactly what this
would have been we don't want to say to
the government oh
you've got a black guy there and a white
guy there let's automatically hire the
black guy that would be a problem that
would be racist
uh 44 which was just over 5 million
people
said uh said yes on it they're they're
all very confused but that's a pretty
decent margin right that's a that's a 12
point margin that's pretty good so that
that is a sign that that a slight
just a very small amount of sanity does
remain here
in california so that's good but i just
wanted to touch one other thing on this
about the confusion of the language so
you look at it you go california
proposition 16. it is to end
the diversity ban well so you diverse
the word diversity is good the word ban
is bad you're going to vote yes on it
that's going to ban the diversity or
take wait what's that
and and they purposely word these things
so i'm going to guess
that something like 20 of the people
that voted on this probably didn't know
if
voting yes meant we're keeping it or
getting rid of it
or anything else end diversity ban and
then what does it do it repeals a
constitution
constitutional provision that made it
unlawful so i'm voting yes
to repeal the ban that what that repeal
that ends the diversity ban that rep you
see what i'm saying here it's very
confusing stuff it's very confusing
stuff but
thankfully thankfully guys um something
something sane actually happened here in
california i can't believe it
what a world it's actually maybe it's
not all terrible who the hell knows
all right guys uh that's it we're on a
tight 24 today
got a busy day obviously doing a bunch
of podcasts and interviews and all that
good stuff
uh stay sane that's going to be my
messaging throughout stay sane
i think we'll get a little more
information out of some of the places
today i think we'll probably
have something on arizona maybe today
it sounds like philly's gonna be hung up
for a little while and as i said they've
got this democratic machine there that
is just not gonna
let trump win um but but all of these
states they're gonna battle it out i
sense this is going to the courts oh
by the way i didn't even mention that
although i wanted to end this on
on a good note so i'm gonna make this
real quick uh crazy
crazy violent protests in new york city
and in portland and in dc and some other
places there's a viral video of just a
girl with no mask on no mask young lady
spitting in a cop's face and then all
sorts of fighting there's people in
portland that are actually going into
residential areas now and screaming at
people
and some poor guy he walks out of his
house and he says no no i'm a biden guy
look i gotta buy it and sign and they
don't care about
that because they want absolute chaos
and it's like wait a minute wait a
minute
what are you guys angry about right now
like we don't even know who won
and the point is they want to burn down
the whole thing either way and
i think a bunch of us were warning about
that but okay that's negative and i want
it to end positive
so i will end positive by saying this
it's all going to be okay one way or
another it's going to be okay
and just remember for all the chaos for
all the chaos right now
the fact that anything can happen
is still good we don't live in a system
where
nobody's vote matters like we vote we
live in a system where
it's a little odd and sometimes even if
you're dead your vote can matter
but like we live in a time where people
are trying to get their voice out and be
heard
that is a net good if you can just you
know see the forest for the trees
okay guys have a great day everybody and
i'll see you tomorrow
you